all right they were fired for their
stance on stopping theft of yoga pants
and their Coward of a boss is glad to
eat the loss Lululemon CEO Dublin down
on firing two workers who tried to stop
a robbery at their George's store
evidently he's pro-robbery which is why
they charge 140 bucks for yoga pants
you remember two women confronted some
masked shoplifter stealing merch the
suspects were eventually arrested
charged with stealing really dumb stuff
but the ladies were canned for violating
the policy on physically engaging
suspects you know I thought it was only
the cops that aren't allowed to chase
criminals
so these ladies are out of work just for
being loyal to their company but the CEO
says the policy is there to keep
employees and customers safe and hey I
bet it's only merchandise
it's only merchandise at the end they're
trained to step back let the theft occur
know that there's technology and there's
cameras and we're working with law
enforcement I get it it's not worth
getting shot over a pair of overpriced
low-rise leggings I don't care how good
they make my butt look
yeah huh you didn't know because I'm
always sitting
but now you know
but it raises the question if it's only
merch why can't we all steal them seems
like the only suckers these days are
people who still pay for this crap why
not just hand out yoga pants at bus
stops and street corners fact is the no
consequences for thievery has hit a dead
and ugly end and I'm sorry to say prison
might be the only part of prison reform
that still works
that's just where you clap
all right
yeah Jimmy uh you don't own anything
worth stealing stop it so is it hard to
relate stop it uh I love do you know
what they about this story that they
call their employees Educators oh really
which is the most pretentious I've ever
heard in my life they're called
Educators they're not employees the CEO
refers to them as Educators be honest if
you're educating people do they pay 140
for pants no like I'm happy they're not
thank you one guy if you could just move
around the room a little bit uh I love
that you got that one no it's the whole
pretentious aspect of this is what you
can't call the cops on them because
Society put them in this position and
it's more dangerous to bring the cops
into a shoplifting situation because
they represent a bad element this is
part of their whole ethos with the sign
on the front of the store which is the
dumbest thing in the world like when the
store like Lululemon is like in this
store we don't tolerate racism bigotry
homophobia like they post that they I
know but they post that as if there's a
store next to it that's like oh we do
come on down I got your bigotry right
here baby it's such a good point and
meanwhile they put their workers in
Jeopardy because they can't be protected
by these these mobs coming in yeah I
don't get I know you know Joe I got to
point out you look great when you wear
Lululemon it's just weird that you you
wear them in the shower
uh it's way weird that you're at my
shower
kinky
it's hot I just know when you work out
you know um this don't try to be a hero
thing it must be hard for someone like
you look Greg Heroes don't ask questions
that's why when I've broken up so many
knife fights they turn out to be dance
teams rehearsing for West Side Story
I'll tell you what I object to the
characterization as the the employees
putting people in danger by saying hey
don't steal stuff it's the criminals
that are putting people in danger by
stealing stuff in the first place and
the politicians that are just letting it
go and letting them out of jail without
a punishment yeah yeah
hang them high that's what I say kill
them all catch
it's something some Maniac might say
[Laughter]
where do you stand or sit pensively well
I'm so glad you asked
I actually I get I understand the policy
because if you go and chase after
somebody who's doing crimes then they
might hurt you like they said kill they
could kill you but they could also hurt
you and then I'm not a lawyer but
couldn't you get like workman's comp for
that right there you go no she's right
she's not sometimes it's about the money
we care about our employees so much it's
probably they care about not having to
pay for a slashed employees and they
don't want to get sued either by the I
mean by the way isn't he arguing against
having a store at all like if you're
saying you know uh like okay if you're
an employee if you're an employee you do
have to have some pride in where you go
to work right and so if you sit if
you're standing there and you've got
your folded whatever leggings and
somebody comes to this it's like why are
you even there but but they're also
making an excuse for all of this crime
he's saying this is okay he's not
punching back at why don't we have
police here we clearly have a lot of
theft this is happening now I agree I
understand the policy because it's
mostly women they're probably not armed
you can't really shoot people that walk
into a store oh you're saying they're
weaker than men I get it we have there
are differences yeah whoa there she said
it not me there are hey oh who let JK
Rowling into the show
holy hell but
they they're the policy is Good from the
standpoint of you have to keep your
employees safe and you should care about
them but I mean do we have like a three
strike policy could we just not say the
first time I mean is maybe you had that
instinct to yell don't steal our stuff
yeah I think that's okay I think that's
acceptable but no it's a it's a no you
don't get any second chances at
Lululemon just so in case you're
planning on working there that's it one
time you screw up you're out I think how
it works I think that this is their
stores will be closed yeah because you
can't you can't do this well that's why
it's so brilliant that he has that
policy because if the stores start
closing then he gets fired and when a
CEO gets fired kaching yes
but can I just add one more thing
they're stealing yoga pants yoga is the
most peaceful activity in the world yeah
these people are not a threat to anybody
it's like they're stealing pillows what
are they going to do beat you up
multiple people in yoga pants way too
many airports why does everybody at the
airport wear Lululemon and the people
who wear them shouldn't be wondering
yeah
they're overconfident because they're
walking around with a better ass than
they have yeah yeah it's disgusting they
look they make my ass look good but my
muffin top look much more noticeable
[Applause]
that's the opposite of arousing okay
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else